un message auquel n'a pas réagi george
bush ce matin il faut dire qu'il doit
surtout faire face à la dernière
décision de la cour suprême des etats
unis
elle vient de déclarer illégaux les
tribunaux militaires d'exception
ces tribunaux avaient été mises en place
vous le rappelle au lendemain des
attentats du 11 septembre
ils concernent essentiellement les
prisonniers de guantanamo laurent
boussier des prisonniers menottés et
accompagner vers le tribunal militaire
de guantanamo voilà ce que les juges de
la cour suprême des etats unis ne
veulent plus voir l'état de guerre ne
justifie pas la mise en place de
procédures judiciaires d'exception
par cinq voix contre trois les membres
de la plus haute autorité judiciaire
américaine ont donc jugé illégale cette
justice militaire instituée après les
attentats du 11 novembre 2001 un
camouflet de plus pour george bush je ne
mettrai pas en danger la sécurité des
citoyens américains
il faut comprendre ça nous sommes en
guerre contre le terrorisme
ces types ont été arrêtés sur un champ
de bataille je protègerai les américains
et en même temps je me soumettrai aux
décisions de la cour suprême
pour l'instant rien ne devrait changer
pour les 450 prisonniers encore détenus
à camp delta
seuls 10 d'entre eux ont été inculpés
devant ces tribunaux d'exception et
aucun procès n'a dépassé le stade des
audiences c'est le cas pour salim hamdan
ancien chauffeur d'oussama ben laden
arrêtées en novembre 2001 en afghanistan
il est à l'origine de la procédure qui a
abouti à la décision de la cour suprême
une décision qui pourrait bien accélérer
la fermeture de guantanamo une prison
qui depuis quatre ans nuit chaque jour
un peu plus à l'image des états unis